what's up my name
let's do this guys scout the new philo
right here
stop it in case you're new here on this
channel guys what we do here is every
friday
we watch the most hilarious clips we
could possibly find
and we try not to laugh now to accept
this challenge guys
is to smash like smash like if you win
and smash like if you lose it's a new
show
i'm trying it out but anyway guys let's
freaking do this first off i challenged
the irish green person he took the
challenge
finally you know what i gotta recognize
it mark however
not a word i bet he's shaking he can't
sleep at night oh i never reacted to
pewdiepie's reaction video that's what
he's thinking
mark what's wrong with you how can you
laugh at this
this is so sad
this is so sad alexa can we hit
50 000 likes jack is making fun of you
alexa are you just gonna take this
your coward just like mark alexa it is
the most advanced iphone we've ever
created
and i'd like to take more of your money
because basically i'm monkey i mean it's
a good
i'm not laughing i am not laughing but
that's a good meme
i said basically a monkey that just
snook out of nowhere basically
me too me hi baby my cats
oh i bet you i bet you 99
of people left come on
what is he doing don't ever explain the
context out of this
the fact that i have no idea where this
is from just makes it so good
give me a good one give me a good meme
hey look it's me
no what are you doing felix
you're not supposed to laugh it feels
very real
look like i'm wielding this gun people
should not let me wield the gun
i mean how do you talk like that i've
said this before but i mean i'm amazed
i'm amazed by his accent
we should not let people build i could i
cannot
i cannot be more swedish when i talk
can you tell am i can you tell
no see i can't even fake my own action
ah
empty your bullets put in one bullet so
you have one bullet in the gun yes
i do okay me too so let's close the gun
okay i started i survive
your turn oh okay
my turn oh i survived your turn
oh okay my turn ah okay your turn
okay my turn oh your turn
okay
[Laughter]
oh my god wait we just oh my god
at the same time that's beautiful oh my
god
we're not going to top that that's
beautiful little father figure he always
does good memes
on march 15th an online explosion
occurred when ninja was joined by
it really bothers me how ninja doesn't
tie his pajama pens
like i get it you're wearing it as a
meme but at least tie them
you're not a savage hip-hop artist drake
for a game of fortnite
yeah drake drake wanted a game wanted a
game
i knew it was time for drake to rise up
[Music]
we have infiltrated the highest level of
your mainstream society
prepare and fear the day that gamers
will finally rise
and take our rightful place as the
leaders
of one something
hey you know what captain marvel looks
great
i actually really want to see it now
is that is that the actual trailer
wait wait sorry wait hold up what is the
context here what's the context just
pieces of the ceiling coming down
a few seconds later customers who packed
into sabroso mexican grilling garden
grove got the shock of their lives
oh my god a woman came through the
ceiling dropping about
25 feet patrons screamed
ah that's hilarious into him that she
was looking for the bus stop she was
looking for the bus stop
she was looking for the busta of course
sorry sorry stop in the ceiling
i'm notorious for hating marvel okay i
don't like him
but can someone explain i know this is
the kind of thing where i will
i will make a statement and everyone
will fill me in and i will feel like an
idiot
but why is she called captain marvel
is that not the dumbest name i have ever
heard for a superhero
what is next mr dc universe person
hey look there he is what the heck
what the frick guys i don't get it can
you come up with any more it's like you
ran out of names
what should we call them captain marvel
copyright also now by disney
what the freak guys cha cha
oh man props for their creativity
it's like you make these random new
movements they're like i have no idea
how anyone would implement that
into anything
did i just rang through a sheep oh
a special move high kick
[Music]
is
you guys have been asking me to watch
this video
[Music]
oh great i was actually
prepared for you to get
to me no
why that video was basically
just
that's all right i do the same thing all
the time there's no shame
actually
introduced it to youtube
i am very happy hey i'm happy too
i'm very happy too this is so fun
i hope
[Music]
oh this is too sweet i can't
you